the area brace for the bad weather
switch from clone will all the way up to
Cumbria the whole west of of England and
Wales indeed and it does scene at this
stage to be the Cornish coastline the
southern Cornish coastline which is
taking and bearing the worst of the
flooding we just hearing that there are
big problems in loo right now popular
fishing village coastal resort that
people go to Paul's F similarly
afflicted Ferry a live a ferry there as
well st. Ives as well very popular
destination flooding problems in all
those places so here in Devon where as
anticipated the worst problems would be
there have been problems but there's
also a degree of preparedness which has
stood them in really good stead
just before I bring in Jason Fowler I
will just show you what we can see from
here because actually somewhere
occasionally this problem here you can
see it well you can't see it but you
there are some bubbles coming up a while
ago take my word for it a drain
absolutely inundated right now and you
can see some of those enormous waves
crashing up against the the seawall
there and all the while the area being
lashed by rain but don't be fooled the
rain that were all been afflicted by it
in recent weeks is less of a problem
than you might think the rivers are
bringing the water down from higher
ground
it's then funneling out into rivers and
estuaries but obviously the land is
saturated that's an ongoing problem
what's happening here today is a problem
the key feature of which is the tidal
surge the high spring tides whipped in
by the strong winds as well just see how
some people live Alex come with me I'll
just show you the view that one person
is waking up to this morning
good morning can you hear us hello give
us a wave there you go extraordinary
absolutely extraordinary in Jason
Farrell Jason you are up here all night
they were ready for this and they were
planning for it but they didn't have
that
no no skepticism about whether it would
be as bad as we predicted obviously they
would concern the Cobra meetings with
the government get them together severe
wear of weather warnings 14 of them down
here in the West Country so this clearly
the area that's most likely to be at
risk but it seems that the conditions
the one factor that might have made it
worse here is that the wind if it have
been northeast lead but it was
southwesterly and that seems to have
helped perfume but obviously as you're
saying down on the south coast of
Cornwall I think well we got it or the
wind is down there anywhere the problem
is it all this as you know Jason you've
followed a few of these things around
it's such an inexact oh there we go it's
such an inexact science isn't it they've
got to prepare for a huge area to be
potentially affected
the more we understand it they're
anywhere from foreign lands lands end
after permit it's going to be probably
the worst affected area but you're right
and he's just never quite know what a
winter swirling abroad I mean they seem
to be changing directions and the
weather is constant Wellington yep you
know wish that one minute heavy heavy
rain